really good piece
um in the guardian by our friend and
former guest on this program Jason
Stanley about the so-called culture war
that seeks to ban ideas and ban books
and remove entire subject matter from an
advanced placement black history course
in Florida and say these books shouldn't
be here those books shouldn't be there
and Jason very eloquently explains in
this article titled Banning ideas and
authors is not a culture War it's
fascism
a lot of the important elements of this
and he says it much more eloquently than
I could so I encourage you to read the
article which we're going to link to in
the description to the YouTube video for
this story but I want to build on this
in some way and tell you some of the
ways in which this sort of ideology has
gone very poorly in the past and agree
with Jason that we really can't when we
say this is part of the culture War some
people want to ban books and some don't
this is part of the culture War some
people want to remove the teaching of
certain
um uh lessons from school curricula and
somewhat it's just a cultural War it's
just a disagreement it is critical that
we see it as a form of fascism and when
you look at history when you look at
regimes that have tried or did ban or
burn books silence dissenting voices it
has frequently ended in tragedy or LED
to absolutely horrible circumstances you
have to look at Nazi Germany the burning
of books was a tactic used to suppress
opposition and impose I guess we would
call it like ideological Conformity you
will conform the Nazis knew books could
be powerful tools for challenging their
world worldview so they set out to
destroy those books and materials that
didn't fit with their narrative the
Soviet Union where the government
maintained really strict control over
what people could read and write
descending voices were silenced anyone
who spoke out could be labeled a traitor
or punished extraordinarily severely in
the United States we've seen attempts to
ban books we've seen attempts to censor
ideas throughout history you go to the
McCarthy era we have these more recent
attempts around critical race Theory the
efforts are always about maintaining
power controlling the narrative and
suppressing dissenting ideas and voices
now this is a really
important uh distinction when we talk
about orwellian versus huxleyan okay
often things are called orwellian in
modern society when really modern
American culture is more hoxland this
book Banning is actually more orwellian
so let me explain this a little bit and
if this is interesting to you it's been
widely written about and explored when
we talk about hoxland we're talking
about Aldous huxili's book Brave New
World
we're talking about a society that is
kind of kept passive and under control
not through force and oppression and the
and the Banning of books but through
pleasure and distraction and
entertainment and that is mostly what we
have when we look I mean Fox News is the
perfect example of hoxland Fox News
mixes opinion and news so you can't tell
which it is they it's the fire Hood a
fire hose falsehood there's just tons of
stuff being pumped out so you don't even
know what's real and what's not Fox News
and right-wing media match real news
reporting with disinformation to the
point where the average person sometimes
is unclear which is the news and which
is the made-up stuff and it encourages
people to be apathetic to be superficial
in their understanding of what's going
on in the world and to Value
entertainment if the news doesn't
entertain me then I'm probably not
watching that's not orwellian most of
what we have in modern American culture
sure is actually huxleyan it's you don't
need to do the orwellian stuff because
people are just going to pay attention
to what's entertaining they can't really
tell the difference they're apathetic
anyway okay
when we talk about the book Banning we
are actually talking about something
that is more orwellian where Society is
controlled through oppression and
surveillance and control
and in a Huxley in society information
and ideas are controlled and manipulated
through culture and entertainment and
you can push ideas out or replace them
with things that are more titillating or
whatever the case may be the book
Banning efforts are much more orwellian
because they are a direct attempt to
suppress ideas and information it's
using government censorship in the case
of Florida it's the idea of the state
government wanting to change or control
what is in the curriculum for that black
history course oftentimes it's powerful
interest groups that are controlling or
whatever the case may be it's a much
more direct form of control orwellian
most of American society is huxleyan the
book Banning efforts should be seen as
forms of fascism and they actually are
orwellian we'll have more about this
discussion on our Instagram so make sure
you are following us there you can
search David Pacman show on Instagram